hello everyone and welcome back to round
10 of the nation's Cup it's a really
really brutal attacking game so I'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it it's a lot of Slav
artemiev also known as chuck norris
versus versus gujarati who who is not
having the greatest tournament so far
but we'll just see what happens in this
game and before we check out the actual
game I do have two very short
announcements first one is who got
dropped another chest song called you
better resign so if you're interested in
checking it out and if you enjoy her
songs to do check it out the link will
be the first thing you see in the
description below and also if you like
to see weird stuff I do suggest you also
check out the second link in the
description below feature some really
weird images like like myself jumping
around on a horsey and well some other
very weird stuff it is just weird but I
can't enjoyed it so do check it out if
you're also interested in in weird stuff
that being said let's check out the game
art image with the white pieces opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 Knight f3
and d5 and here Artemyev goes for Bishop
to g5 the Tauri attack
we have nicely for immediately
challenging the bishop with better back
to h4 and the Queen to b6 now now
getting away from this pen you will be
able to push east 65 in the future but
also it's it's an online where the Queen
comes to it comes to h6
so Knight B to d2 now with ideas of
trading night and now Queen to h6
preventing this because if you trade
right away characters captures then your
knight who is defending the bishop is
under attack and you will lose one of
these pieces so after Queen e6 we have
Queen to see one now again introducing
the threat of off trading pieces because
first you are gonna trade the Queen's
and then it's not a problem since your
Bishop will not be under attack you'll
be able to move your f3 Knight so here
g5 buy with it and now Knight captures
on e4 so grabbing that night we have D
captures on e4 and now Bishop captures
on g5 first grabbing the pawn Queen to
h5 and now Knight back to g1 so here we
have this situation
white was forced to retreat a night back
but black also has only a queen
developed so it's it's a really weird
situation we have the shop the g7 just
continuing development attacking the d4
pawn and c3 now and the position has
been reached before E 5 is a known
moving the position striking the center
immediately but with it decides to go
for c5 which again just challenged at
the center but with the C pawn and it is
already as a remove 10 that we have a
completely new game so we've Bishop back
to d2 and now Knight to c6 are putting
more pressure after the d4 pawn if you
want to grab it right away it's not
really possible since Queen captures and
C it would be checkmate just if anyone
missed that so tonight the c6 putting
more pressure to d4 and now III just
strengthening the center with Bishop to
g4 and now comes Knight to e2 continuing
developing the white still has to figure
out how he will go about it while he was
on g3 Bishop g2 or maybe Nigeria attack
the Queen followed by Bishop e2 by
castles but it's a it's not at all clear
that since black does have a semi-open G
file for his rook if white is eager to
Castle kingside
so here evaded castles Queen side which
is very nice pushes rook on the D file
why things still being in the center but
now Artemia starts starts a very very
interesting attack he first goes b4 and
okay obviously you're threatening to
pick up the the c5 pawn it's defended
its already attacked twice so here C
captures and B for C captors and before
is also possible but we did decides for
C characters and before we have C
capture some before and now just King to
be 8 so the knight can move you don't
want to keep working on the same file as
the Queen and now white still has to
figure out how to continue development
you can still go Knight the g3 maybe
play Bishop b2 Bishop somewhere then
maybe castle but it is a bit dangerous
since black does have a semi-open G file
so here are Tamia plays the most
interesting b5 and it's a it's not a
pawn you can refuse since the Knight has
no squares the bishop slices all the way
here the pawn covers e5 all of D square
are covered so the knight doesn't have a
retreat square so you do have to capture
it
Soviet captures the pawn and now rook
the b1 using this pawn sacrifice to to
start an attack as the black queen is
now under attack
so Queen d5 and now Knight to c3 so
grabbing yet another tempo with an
attack on the Queen Queen to e6 and now
Knight to a4 going for c5 which will
create a double attack on the Queen end
on the b7 pawn so here at villa decided
to go king to a8 not to have his King on
the same file as the rook but this
doesn't work so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find why it
doesn't work while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the B fork that lurks in the
position and for those of you that want
to enjoy the show it's of course rook
captures on b7 now the point is if King
captures you again have the fortnight's
the c5 check picks up the Queen and if
you don't you have to play something
else so here we did tried Queen to d6
getting the Queen out of out of forks
reach but now still Knight the c5 so now
it's very hard for black to find the
move ideas like Bishop the c8 come to
mind to kick away the the rook from the
active b7 Square but here they they
decided that since Optima already
sacrificed material he wants to
sacrifice back and start an attack of
his own white King still being in the
center it does make sense but here
there's another problem
artemyev doesn't recapture because there
is a forced checkmate in six moves in
the position so once again feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
force the mating sequence well I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations as you are also awarded
on Morphy head and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's rook
captures on a7 and again it's not a not
a rook sacrifice you can decline for
example if you go rook to b8 just queen
bee - or queen bee one wins the game on
the spot King King goes somewhere and
Queen b7 is checkmate
so visit of course had the capture
but now it's Queen a3 check we have King
Derby six now comes Queen to b4 check
King to c6 and now of course bring the
king deeper into the position Queen to
b7 check just drive the King down the
board we have King captures on c5 and
now of course Bishop to b4 check which
is which is in fact checkmate as the
light square Bishop prevents the King
from going to at the c4 the Queen covers
these squares so the King has no squares
and it's checkmate and it's really
really just a remarkable position I
really enjoyed checkmates where the
bishops do old all the slicing and well
the king is on c5 so an extremely a
beautifully played game by artemiev but
you know good for Vida too to try and
play in great style as it always takes
to to create to create a great game so
yeah I do a ward Artemyev the morphe
head there we go as this is this is
quite a beauty quite an attacking game
so I do I do hope you enjoyed it and
like I said do check out a hookahs video
it will be the first link in the
description below and do check out the
weird video where I jump around on a
horsie it will be the second link in the
description below so yeah that's the
game from round 10 of the Nations Cup
we're gonna check out some other games
and also we have the super final
starting today so we're gonna check out
some games games from that as well sure
I would like to thank all Morell trolley
Johnny
Jakob since Drago Drago meter across
Marshall and Chris carska Dan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Nations Cup and well we are continuing
some as some other service and when it
finishes so I think I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day